[Music]
let's go out
to Veronica in Sacramento before we get
cancelled what's up Veronica hi Dr John
thank you for taking my call thank you
for calling what's up so my partner and
I split about six weeks ago because he
said so sorry he said he had been
unhappy for some time and had some work
to do on himself he continues to say he
hopes we find our way back to each other
sometime down the road after we've both
had time to heal work on ourselves and
hopefully come back together with a new
way of doing things he began dating
other women a week after we broke up
right um we share a two-year-old and I
have committed to remaining excuse
me I've committed to remaining in his
other kids's life he has a seven and an
11y old okay we still do family
activities and seing him semi semi
regularly excuse me and his statements
of Hope are confusing and I'm unsure how
to grieve let go of Hope and move
forward and just for additional context
when when we first started dating he had
been married for 14 years and his wife
had had an affair and left and I I had
known both him and his wife for quite a
while before then and he had reached out
and at the time I told him you know I
think you need to spend a year figuring
out who you are outside your marriage
reach out to me I'm single in a year
great and when he continued to pursue me
I told myself a story that it was meant
to be he was choosing and picking
me and we got pregnant almost
immediately which was not planned and
that put a lot of pressure on the
relationship and he has explained in the
breakup that he is a police officer he
did two tours in Afghanistan he came
back and got married and then we
immediately got pregnant so he does not
feel like he has had the last 20 years
he's been in some type of intense
situation and he has not had time to
figure out who he is or what he wants
and so for me I can understand on some
levels that he needs to figure out who
he is but he lost that privilege when he
had a baby with
you
period the figuring out days the
backpacking through Italy days the going
out on a bunch of different dates with a
bunch of different people to get to know
folks and figure out what you like and
don't like those days are over he's
created two different family units with
two different women and three
kids those are all choices that he
made the hardest thing for you to hear
right now is just the truth and I'm
going to be honest with you is that cool
I I absolutely hope you'll be truthful
with me all right this relationship's
over
period there might be a time in the
future that y'all rebuild something new
but what you had is over complete stop
sign it's done over over the land has
been sold to somebody
else here's where that's really hard for
you yes because you have to you have a
child now
right you also I have a child and he his
two kids I've been in therapy um and his
two kids are seven and 11 years old they
in his previous marriage they couldn't
have children so they adopted them and I
feel like the adoption was one form of
Abandonment the divorce was another and
I just I know Veronica but but here's
the thing you can commit all you want
you're not invited into their life I I
am actually he's he's for me to yeah
because you're a babysitter while he's
out hooking up with other
people you're an amazing free babysitter
that's not being in their life that's
being taken advantage of yeah yeah and
you can't use them and they're and you
can't use them to make yourself feel
better about this disaster that's upon
you yeah he left he left you with a baby
he left you with a bunch of
promises so you have these two things
you're grieving one is the actual loss
of the relationship he's probably a
pretty fun guy to be around right when
he's fully plugged in right and you'll
have a baby together is it a boy or a
girl boy so do you see his daddy in him
every second of every day yes yeah
that's both amazing and hell in this
situation the second thing that you have
to grieve it's that's different than
that is you lost trust in Veronica
because you
knew yeah and now you don't know which
way to what like every step you take is
like trying to walk on a on a
lake because you don't trust you don't
trust you right
yeah and how old are you I'm
40 have you been married before when I
was 23
okay oh dude so you went all back in on
this one huh I I was I have never been
as all the way in with someone as I have
with him oh
man I'm so
sorry I bet you don't feel like you have
any guts right now do you
none
none and I just you know you know I've
listened to your show for a long time
and I appreciate when you share that
like I want to be a mature adult and be
able to be around him and and co-parent
peacefully and we we get along fine you
know we went took the whole family to an
air show this past weekend and then but
it while I loved us all being together
it was also super painful for me and I
just yeah it's pretend it's pretend
you're playing family yes and he's
playing family and then he got home and
he texted the other girl when he got
home right right
right I hate that for you I'm so
sorry I just I don't know how to let go
of hope I'm just move forward I
know I
know does he want to be in this little
baby's life or is he just dragging on
the whole thing a great dad okay he's a
great dad and that's so I think that's
part of it you know because I love him
and I love seeing him with my son and I
always wanted to be a mom and I didn't
get to be until I was 37 I know you are
a mom and it feels right but now half of
this life I don't get to see anymore you
know and I don't get
to see the joy that comes from watching
the two of them interact and
yeah
I'm sorry dude that picture you had was
you all painted it together and it was
going to be
forever
yeah I'm so
sorry the
um I think the important thing moving
forward is I think he's told you enough
stories and here's going to sound
something crazy I think in his heart and
head there's a chance your husband is
not all evil I think there's actually a
chance that he is trying to unravel this
thing on his
own at all at the same time he's trying
to probably honor his first wife and
those two kids however messy that is and
he's trying to honor you and this new
baby however messy that is and he still
has this other part of him that feels
like was stolen from him while he was
deployed and he wants that too it's it's
a hard I I get it I don't agree with it
and if he was sitting down with me I
would say bro but I get it I understand
it what that means
is you have to take back agency over
Veronica's
life and that starts with you telling
him I refuse to be the other
woman I'm just not unless you're okay
with
that I'm not I know you're not I mean
you're not you know I'm still close to
this whole family you know they love me
and like I'm a good mom I know you are
hold on hold on whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa don't you dare hang up this phone
thinking that he left you because of
you because you weren't a good
mom he was pretty clear I left because
of me right because of him yeah yeah
well yes and
he I mean he did say he felt like I had
things to work on I think we we all do
have things that we're trying to work on
grief yeah you find me two people who
get married who don't have things to
work on good grief that's not even a
real
statement it's not even real of course
be kind and loving and have integrity
and that guy must have been an honor
student well you've got things to work
on too well no kidding genius but here's
the deal from this point forward you
have to draw boundaries around you and
your well-being and the well-being of
your
child that means as awful as this sounds
you're going to have to go sit with an
attorney and create actual parenting
guidelines and
boundaries and I know that's not fun I
know that
sucks no and especially because we've
tried to write out our own custody
agreement be very flexible it's not
gonna
work it's going to work until he starts
dating somebody else and gets engaged
again and she wants her life to look a
different
way and then he's going to be obligated
to honor his new wife it's the right
thing to do and it's going to get
messy and so what you're doing is saying
hey you chose to
leave I love you I honor your choice now
I have to protect me and I have to
protect this baby and we're going to put
some of these things in writing I love
you I'm always going to be with you
you're just giving up on us no no no no
no you left you
left
period you see the difference I do okay
I do and if 50/50 custody doesn't work
out on a regular basis when it comes to
travel and picking up from school and
work schedules then it doesn't work and
you can tell
them I think the best schedule is going
to be X Y and Z I don't want to go to
court I don't want to fight
you you are a great dad to this little
boy but you get to create the world and
put it in front of them and see see if
he signs it
right but I think you have to bring
another person in on this deal you also
have to make sure you're covered
financially I I mean I'm very fortunate
that you know I've followed Dave Ramsey
have no Deb I have a really good job
right now good career right
now I would not have a job if
everybody's good job lasted forever I
would be unemployed if everybody's great
great awesome moments lasted forever
they don't
layoffs happen people get fired and that
kid's still going to need to
eat and you've been independent for a
long time you're tough aren't you yeah
and you'll be damned if you're gonna ask
some man to get put money in your
account right yes you have
to it's for this little boy and you're
playing a long-term game to this little
boy's 18 if you don't want to take
alimony that's fine but there has to be
some
participation in the day-to-day um
expenses of raising a
kid yeah right yes now is not a time for
your ego Now's the Time to take care of
this little boy in the short term and in
the long
term yeah the chances that you still
have this great job and this great
opportunity in the great state of
California when he's 18 is slim to
none well I mean I'm gonna push back on
that a little bit just because of my
training and in my profession I can I'm
I'm a nurse so so you're pry decent job
security unless in three years the
diagnostic system with AI begins to let
people do it at from their
house and you've seen that technology
coming out just like I have right right
yes everyone's got a great job till they
don't those dudes who used to create the
pooper scoopers for the horses were
sitting pretty until Henry Ford came
along
right right so I and again I think in 20
years we're still going to have nurses
don't get me wrong I hope to God we do
for sure well I mean what I feel like I
hear you saying is that I really need to
advocate for myself and make sure that
I'm secure and my son is secure in
writing in an official state document
yes yeah I I hear you because I have sat
with too many people 5 years from now
when he's married to somebody else and
she's pregn
and she says you will not have those
kids in this house period this is new
lifetime yeah and suddenly great dad
disappears just like a
ghost and how he pitched in for
groceries and you always just had money
because he was a cool guy now suddenly
that's her money too and I ain't sending
nothing to ex
nobody and that's just I I mean it's
just happened my whole career right
right
H maybe he's not man this dude's
amazing he just got in over his head and
you y'all were friends and then he
really liked you and he hooked up and
he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa this
is happening again too fast and then
suddenly you had a baby and you know I
said maybe that's what how how that
happened I don't want to knock the guy
but um I do think it's wise for both of
you to have this thing secured and you
to advocate for yourself both now and 18
years from
now
I hate it for you so a quick thing I
think is helpful when you're grieving
helps clarify things you've heard me say
this a bunch on this show but I want you
to do this I want you to write him three
letters that you will never never going
to send him letter number one is anger
heartbreak sadness I can't believe you
left
us I'm so heartbroken that you left
us you made promises to me you swore to
me and you're gone letter number two is
I'm so grateful you came into my life
and this just usually the Hard One to
write because because of your time
together with him you got this amazing
amazing little
boy he is a good
dad so
here's you let me believe again whatever
you want to write but the second letter
is how much um you're glad he came into
your life the third letter is
dear dear
ex I want you know what you're going to
miss I'm going to be an amazing mother
to our
kid I'm going to make sure and want you
go on the list he's gonna have a healthy
breakfast that when he starts dating
that I'm not that crazy mom who wants to
fight his girlfriends but I'm gonna be
we're going to talk about sex and we're
going to talk about life and we're going
to talk about philosophy and politics
I'm going to beat there for our son
you're going to miss it all cuz you left
you'll get the games and you'll get the
fun but you're going to miss watching an
amazing mom love her
son and as you write those things you're
going to begin to feel things things are
going to come up I want you to write
those things that come up and I want you
to take time to weep like you haven't
wept
yet you take time to be heartbroken and
be scared and be like I knew it Veronica
you shouldn't have done it again and yes
you should
have this is all part of the healing
Journey the final thing is is you have
to find two or three women that you
trust and sit down and tell them
everything all of how much you're
hurting you've heard me say this a
million times I'll say it a million more
as David Kessler says grief Demands a
witness you have to sit in front of
somebody and say this happened to
me this happened to somebody I
love I was single and strong for so long
and nobody messed with me and then I
fell head over heels and with a guy I
knew I shouldn't have and he made me a
bunch of promises and we have this
beautiful baby boy and then he left
me and I'd take him back if he said all
that all of it all of it all of it got
to say it out loud in front of other
real people in real
time and that's the beginning of the
grieving
process over and over and over again I'm
super grateful for you Veronica I'm so
sorry this happened what y'all had is
over now he could Circle back and be
like I was wrong I screwed up whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm all in I'm all
in I'm all in okay fine y'all got to
build something completely new and he's
got a lot of trust rebuilding to
do what you had is over the only place
you can go is forward now and in the
interim you got to take care of you and
you got to take care of this little boy
I'm grateful for you holler anytime if I
can be of
help